Hello, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys.
Dan, do you know what else
is a bloody good channel
for YouTube?
Go on.
The hydraulic press channel.
Yeah, it's pretty sweet.
We've got one here.
It is massive.
Yeah.
Look at the size of the thing.
It actually goes about probably
12, 15 feet up in the air.
It's huge.
And I've learnt from that channel,
that pretty much anything explodes
if you press on it hard enough.
Including, a deck of cards,
which I just happen to have in my car.
I know, we've never seen, I've never seen
the hydraulic press blow
something up in slow motion.
No.
So we're gonna film this
at 28,500 frames a second,
which is over a thousand
times slower than you can see
with your own face.
So on the hydraulic press channel,
the cards explode basically.
So to protect us and the camera,
we've had to put this thick
screen in front of us.
Because I don't really particularly want
a piece of card going through
my jugular as we're filming.
Kill buddy is suspended.
Yeah, so if it does explode,
I wanna be protected, instead of...
Thankfully this hydraulic press,
you can see all the way
through to the other side.
'Cause typically it's quite hard to light
inside machinery like that.
And we also got ourselves a
lovely, bright light here,
that I'm blasting down in
the face of Dan right now.
So we should get some
nice exposure on this.
And we have 25,
30, 40,
50,
60, 70,
80,
90.
Oh God.
Flip.
Oh my God.
Well this is all we got
left, it's this and this.
So this is actually all 52 cards
compressed as much as possible.
So technically this is a full
deck of cards right here.
Every single card in the deck is squashed.
Sort of like crushes it back to wood.
It does, it's pretty solid,
I wonder if it will snap.
I thought we were gonna die.
Yeah, glad we had that cover,
because all the cards
flung out everywhere,
all over the floor.
Well I thought that was a lovely
little tribute video there.
Nice, quick, easy one.
Pick a card, any card.
Okay.
Well you've got the
jack of diamonds there.
Yeah.
Yeah, you weren't supposed
to show me, but...
Oh, sorry, yeah.
Well, all you have to do is
say, "Is this your card?"
And the answer is yes.
'Cause it's definitely...
Its every card
Yeah.
All right, well, feel free
to follow us on Twitter.
We've got so much, we've
got a lovely second channel.
And do let us know in the comments,
if you'd like to see any
more slow-mo hydraulic press.
I'm sure we can make that one happen.
This is the only one that's intact.
All right, we'll see you in the next one.